hello this is Douglas Tyrion also known
as that kind of the glasses I'm here
with my brother Rob who co-wrote this
sketch and we're also here with the star
Victoria say hello Victoria she did a
very very good job here and actually
provided a lot of wardrobe too didn't
didn't show you got the wings and
everything yeah and one of the things is
you know we're talking about doing
another episode because people really
seem to like this and definitely one of
the first things were going to change is
the the setting because it looks like
it's in a basement there's a good reason
it was in a basement this this was
actually done for a couple of investors
who wanted to see something that we
could do quick and on the fly so we have
two days to do this which is why the
production values are even worse that
are normally pretty shoddy production
values and here yet a dance without
music right yeah it was just like oh
just jump up and down and move around
I'm not a good dancer anyway so what and
the interesting thing too is that you I
forget it did you know who your clothes
before you did this I said I can I
really wanted a strong dress we just
went through my closet
we could chew as yours to you can run
over this entire collection of strange
plush visa mr. Cogan is mine yeah I was
gonna say opponent easy I don't know why
right and snip these there just needed
something cut too and why I'm Edward
Norton is good we're trying to think of
some celebrity I look some semblance
like and that's like the closest thing
we could think of so and you have this
sort of naturally nasal voice to be a
yeah so I try to make it a little more
nasally by the kind of just resorted
back to my you do much better and you
did a much better ever ignored after the
fact so yeah thanks a lot for saving
your worst material for the sketch and
holding out in your best material for I
love my lucky give there you know
doesn't look I gave when I was a little
kid when I didn't get my anyway
it's very effective am i right everybody
still just out no versus butterfly
sometime they start changing it to
things like monkeys kanji butterflies is
the battle cry of the Bjork show and
it's fine because this was done so fast
we thought that this was gonna be really
hard to edit but because it's so strange
we could just throw in whatever like
that point where it just freezes and
says like me it's like thousand Lee done
because it wasn't I couldn't cut to
anything else by I mean it just it works
because everything else is so straight
yeah the the beauty of the Bjork show is
I love the George Wendt is it was sort
of an anything-goes sketch the idea I
had was that it was sort of um there you
are oh my god
yes hung over I might add we uh we did
this the day after a Halloween party and
vixx was a trouper because I actually
cover up the sketch early the next
morning after the party picked you up
took you out to lunch and you read the
script in the car and then hit to
perform this and we shot this over the
course of three hours yeah yeah like
learning it literally that morning
didn't have a script and somehow we
didn't spend a whole lot of time
laughing about it I think I laugh about
it more afterwards
Oh you're surrounded by this stuff the
stuff that makes no sense I mean it's
hard to really you just scratch your
head saying okay this adds up this
bologna sandwich bit came out of my
original concept of the show which was
that it was like pee-wee's Playhouse
only whereas the furniture could really
talk on pee-wee's playhouse my idea was
she talked to the furniture and all the
DS objects and they can't talk but she's
convinced they can for some reason and
no one else shares this neurosis but her
and just gets creeped out by it very
fast uh I think it's funny that you guys
didn't know if I could actor we've never
seen you act I mean when we invite
friends to do these servings we have no
idea
so you know it's always just a big
gamble but you had there is just
something in your personality that just
seemed to match that sort of your
quality which is sort of this whispery
sort of wistful whimsical
yeah iconic you know especially like
right here where that's my favorite but
yet heaven is heaven when we would talk
of just blurting out random things out
of nowhere random words and I think
that's why we sort of at least in my
head why I sort of gravitated towards
you because I was like you're you kind
of have that quality to begin with
that's also the only one with dark hair
that is that's not good you're good
actress it's just because you get bit
yes yes we got you for your hair right
we had to we have to really teach you
how to kind of sing like Bjork because
it's actually hard to sing like Bjork
yes you sang it too good yeah we have to
make it worse there's a band a better
one though yeah there's a close-up you
just saw there it drives me nuts because
I forgot to film a close-up sight to do
it in the computer it looks so bad
that's the one thing that I won't change
and this this whole seven days thing is
a trick that Victoria has pulled on me
numerous times because she get as she
pulls her hair down and she knows that I
find the movie Oh what was that movie
the green creepy and she would just
randomly do that so we just decided to
incorporate it this is another creepy
thing Bjork does those are two
impressions you do well Bjork at the
ring girl yes aren't you proud well
thanks for being here say goodbye
everybody